it's never easy it's never an easy time
to be enough artist I don't think it's
ever been easy
iced knit it's not an easy thing it's
not easy to make a living as an artist
never has been and I think the
challenges now have replace whatever the
challenges were before and it is quite
tough but otherwise everyone would be
doing it's amazing because it was
unexpected and I've always enjoyed it
I've always felt really pleased for
people I was really really pleased for
dizzy when he won out I thought that was
there was a lot of great happens that
year and I thought he but his win was
really deserved so I've always enjoyed
it I've always like looked at it to see
if there were new records I didn't know
and that I've been gonna listen to so
it's obviously it's a rule it's a real
honor to be in it and I think genuinely
because it's a thing where doesn't
really matter if you could actually win
it or not but to had better to be
included in it I know people always say
that about Wars but I think with this
one IHG that to be included in it